You mentioned several times the dangers of running pro wave frequencies through the bomb setting, but the other day I realized I ran the I am pro wave settings with the pro wave attached and the pro wave was blinking as usual is this is that also damaging the right.
So I think what you're saying is the other day you have the bulb settings with the pro wave attached or did you see I ran the I am pro wave with the bulb attached because you'd always run the pro wave with the pro wave attached.
So the thing that you have to be careful of is that on the true right you need the switch switch to bat when you run the I am pro wave.
So you said yes the switch was set to bulb so if you ran the I am pro wave with the switch set to bulb because you have the I am pro wave plugged in it still may blink.
But it doesn't mean that the frequencies are coming out of there and there's any energy that's going to it.
Can you damage the I am pro wave by having it set to bulb and running I am pro wave settings while you will damage the I am pro wave, but you could damage the bulb.
So if you didn't have the bulb connected, which you should always leave the bulb connected.
But if you didn't have the bulb connected and you ran an I am pro wave program with your I am pro wave plugged in and hadn't switched to bulb by accident while you were running the I am pro wave.
You would probably get our keep that go between these two little ports here and be going back and forth on the red and black and if you touched it you'd get a shock.
You always should have your bulb plugged in when you run the I am pro wave you should always have the bulb plugged in when you run the I am pro wave.
And of course you have the bulb plugged in when you run the bulb program.
So you risk damaging the bulb when you run an I am pro wave program.
But you have this switch to bulb in the reason is the bath has the I am pro wave programs have different duty cycles.
You risk burning out the cord you risk burning out.
You know, damaging your bulb in some way. Now if you just didn't once, chance you damage your bulb is probably zero.
But if you did this on a regular basis, then you could damage the bulb, but you notice it won't work or the cord is damaged.
Or it smells burned there's a burn smell or something like that.
So if it's working just fine after this you go, oh my gosh, did I just did I just ruin something because I had to switch to bulb the whole time.
Well, if you turn back on to a bulb program and you leave it on switched to bulb will you do that obviously.
And it's running just fine and you don't have any of those issues that it's you didn't damage anything, but you do risk that damage.
So always when you're running the I am pro wave you have to switch to bath.
When you're running the bulb you have a switch to bulb and at all times you have your bulb plugged in.
Now this is the older F122 model in just a couple of questions later. There's another question about the difference between them. So I'll get to that.